all right so modern warfare 2 is
officially announced we now have
trailers for it
and we got to see it um i can't actually
tell you what i played unfortunately i
am still embargoed under that but
luckily for you we had a two-hour
presentation that was followed by
hands-on session and i can tell you
about a lot of things uh first i gotta
start with a bit of housekeeping um and
just disclose that infinity war did fly
us down for this preview event but other
than that everything is just our
thoughts and impressions of this game
[Music]
so starting off aaron why don't you tell
me about ground war and what modern
warfare 2 has in store for ground war
so ground war oh my god the fans are
going to be really excited about this so
modern warfare 2019 you know attracted a
big battlefield crowd because
battlefield was kind of not doing so
great at that time and it's not doing so
great now again um so ground war is now
part of a larger battle mode in in
modern warfare 2. so it's just one of
the modes and and we saw ground war we
didn't see what the other modes are but
there was something really interesting
so the devs basically said that across
the entire game all of the mechanics go
everywhere so like single-player warzone
um co-op and spec ops which they hinted
at so they said that they were testing
something like 50 players versus up to
300 ai
they didn't tell us exactly how that's
going to play into this larger battle
mode but they just hinted at what they
were capable of doing there's two maps
that that we were shown one is much
bigger and more purpose-built they
talked about how it was tough last time
around when they made ground war they
just sort of haphazardly put things on
bergansk
which it still played really really well
but this time they're making them
purpose-built
there is a lot of interior space like
every single building that we saw had
interior spaces and you could go floor
to roof there's also now
water on the map like some of the
battlefield maps so one map we saw had a
giant lagoon to one side with an
objective on an island
so it's just uh it's an expansion of
ground war if you already liked ground
war you're getting a bigger sandbox and
a bigger set of purpose-built maps we
also saw another map that looked a lot
like promenade so i think they are
trying to keep in mind that some players
do want that really quick action but
even the promenade map had a lot of
interior spaces so
it is for modern warfare players who
like those open layouts the open design
and again probably not as much for the
you know the cold war classic call of
duty players who
like small tight three-lane
kind of maps
now that being said that's the bigger
thing
the smaller thing is the core 6v6 this
one is actually more for the cold war
fans these maps were tighter they were
smaller in many cases than some of the
modern warfare 2019 maps
and um
i don't know if i can go into too much
detail but visually they reminded me a
little bit more of cold war maps so it
seems like they're trying to split the
difference go bigger on ground war and
go sort of smaller more competitive
focused than the core 6v6
so when you're talking about vehicles
i'm curious about you know vehicles are
such a big part of battlefield's all-out
warfare and call of duty's take with
ground war is there any kind of new or
consistent like infantry interaction
with your vehicles the way that you you
know when you think back to a game like
battlefield hardline you used to be able
to kind of like break out of windows and
aim out you know the passenger side seat
with like an ar or something how is call
of duty handling vehicles in ground war
yeah so across the board they've had a
lot of tweaks to vehicles and i think
people will be most excited about this
in warzone actually because this is
where it'll have the greatest impact so
there's two things that really stood out
um one of them was they've overhauled
the amount of things you can do to
vehicles so you can break off bumpers
you can blow out tires you can blow off
doors uh i was firing an anti-material
rifle and having a really good time
doing this kind of stuff
um you can also get out sorry you can
lean out but you can lean out on the
driver's side and the passenger side now
and you can also get on the roof almost
like just cause style now the other
thing is there's like a repair torch so
like it'll be nice like people destroy
your vehicle and the repair torch is
useful now you can repair it and then
keep moving so again that's in ground
war and that's also in warzone um
there's another really cool touch so
they've they've like doubled down on
vehicles um there's water vehicles a lot
of the vehicles are amphibious but
there's a giant transport helicopter
that's going to be in every mode and
even if you're piloting it if you get
out of the pilot seat it has an interior
cargo bay
so you can walk around the cargo bay and
shoot out of it snipe out of it fire
rockets out of it it's really cool to
have this like giant interior space in a
moving vehicle so it just opens up a lot
of um sandbox possibilities that's
interesting so you're not you're not
stuck in like a seat like you would be
out of like another like attack chopper
like in an attack chopper in battlefield
or something you know you would usually
have those two turrets or you even if
you were just using your uh your own gun
you would kind of be locked in almost
like an on-rail type situation so here
you're actually able to just run around
shoot out through different angles
yeah and and that's why in warzone i
always jumped on top of cars instead of
got into cars because i didn't like the
the limit that you could like swing
because you could you could get caught
by somebody and you couldn't get to them
um so it kind of gets gets rid of that
thing where you have to like sort of
like cheat by jumping on top not cheap
but like exploited by jumping on top of
vehicles as opposed to getting in
what they did change was the the perk
system so the perks now come in packages
um it's kind of like how the the
specialist system that you could select
worked in 2019 but it's on all the time
now so what you do is you pick two perks
then you earn a bonus perk and then you
earn an ultimate perk so
that's kind of cool because it means you
can at least in the core multiplayer it
means that you could sort of like
quickly switch between packages of perks
and you weren't instantly powerful so
like it rewarded you for playing and the
better you did the more perks you got
which again is consistent with that
older system that you could tackle on or
off so it'll be interesting to see how
people
adapt both their loadouts and also their
perk packages which is kind of a new
thing so taking things back towards uh
talking about the sandbox and stuff
there's obviously a bunch of equipment
and different tools they can kind of use
in your combat what kind of uh what kind
of equipment and tools did you see ooh
sandbox this is my favorite thing in the
whole world okay so this kind of ties
everything together this ties together
vehicles this ties together water and
this ties together that sort of milsim
thing that people love
a lot of the gadgets were
near future
they actually some of them seem very
rainbow six siege inspired there's a
camera that's very much like rainbow six
siege that everybody can throw around
the map and it networks so your whole
team can look through the camera that
one seem more useful for like core modes
competitive core modes where you're
trying to tell where the other team is
um there were two modes we played one
was like grab the hostage and the other
was last one holding a bag so maybe
that's where that's useful but then
there comes the really fun stuff so
there's now a drill charge in the game
like i believe fuse from rainbow six
siege and you can throw it through
there's gonna be so many good myth
buster episodes the drill charge you can
stick to floors walls ceilings doors or
people
and it'll drill in and after second you
know throw a grenade into the room so
it's really good for getting into rooms
where somebody's entrenched or like
camping
but it's also against vehicles so if you
hit a vehicle with it it'll start
drilling into the side of the vehicle
and they get a warning and it forces
people out of that vehicle because if
they stay inside they'll probably die
so they're thinking a lot more about the
like the equipment vehicle interaction
so people have more tools to deal with
it you can also combo it with they had
something called ddos which is basically
an electromagnetic pulse that shut down
vehicles and the driver would have to be
frantically trying to start it up so
they talked about you know like you hit
the vehicle with a pulse and then you
hit it um with this charge and so you've
like screwed everybody like quite
literally screwed everybody inside of
the vehicle they have to get out or
they're done
so it's cool um oh
there's one there's one really good one
i have no idea if this one's gonna be
useful at all
but there's a blow up dummy
and there's a lot to this blow up dummy
so like
you throw the dummy down and you can
either manually inflate it or you can
set it to trigger inflate when something
walks by it
and i can just imagine the first time
you walk into a room where like 10 of
these have been put down and have a
heart attack when like 10 dummies all
like suit like it's airbag they like
airbag inflate all at the same time
um you can also use them as like a towel
so if you throw it like down by a window
and someone enters the room it'll like
snap inflate towards that person
so it'll surprise them and also give you
information as to where they are
how long people will fall for that i'll
have to ask people who like alibi maine
in rainbow six siege
um
but man it was
i i don't know if it's gonna be useful
but it's gonna be funny as hell uh to to
myth bust that one and just kind of try
it out
it seemed to soak damage too i don't
know like it's
just kind of silly and fun i think
that's what they're going for like their
overall theme of this game was to try
and be a little bit more lighthearted
than the last one
well yeah for sure 2019 got really
really dark in some areas uh you know
almost when you least expected it which
actually is a great segue into the
campaign so modernware for 2019's
campaign despite obviously having some
historical inaccuracies uh to a fault
but the the mood and the theme and the
tension of that campaign i personally
actually really enjoyed and even going
back to modern warfare one two and three
that trilogy was probably one of my
favorite from like a story and a
campaign perspective set pieces a lot of
you know high octane action and some
really great characters and storytelling
so
you know obviously uh captain price is
back and
as a soap and so i was hoping you could
uh kind of
tell me if you saw anything about that
campaign i'm dying to know
so it's funny i got a little bit of
mixed messaging on the campaign it
they're trying to make the campaign
less thought-provoking i would say than
the previous one they're trying to play
it a little bit safer so what that looks
like that looks like um there's we
actually saw a bunch of close quarters
combat like a lot like the clean house
mission in london
but they took out a lot of the the
civilians and the things that really
made you like
think about not wanting to shoot things
it's mostly it was just full of bad guys
so
what they're kind of trying to do
overall with the campaign is they're
trying to take a lot of the greatest
hits like all gillied up and and
missions like it and add a twist to it
um what we'll see if they can pull off
is
you know it's either gonna be like oh my
god this is incredible nostalgia this is
super clever or like they're gonna have
a challenge to create their own identity
as a game we don't know which way it's
gonna go just yet
a lot of those missions incorporated
water as mentioned water came up quite a
lot um so yeah water close combat but
then they're adding a bunch of other
mechanics there was like a gta style
level with people like you know climbing
on cars and jumping car to car in a car
chase
then they told us about the plot and the
plot is that they
uh america has killed a foreign general
this sounds familiar to some of you
and that
foreign entity is basically seems like
contracting
cartels in mexico to retaliate so task
force 141 is basically hunting down
those who are going to retaliate around
the world before that they can do this
retaliation so i think high level that's
still sort of grounded in real world
events but moments of moment they're
playing it a lot safer like i wasn't
you know wasn't bursting in any rooms
with like babies or anything like that
in it which i actually i liked i liked
that about 2019 because it was the first
time in a call of duty game where i
didn't want to shoot something which is
saying a lot i mean i've never played a
call of duty game that like
made me think that much
so they're not trying to do that they're
trying to make it a little bit more just
fun for people so following up on the
campaign you mentioned that the united
states kills a foreign general which you
know lmao um but where does that take
you what kind of locations are we seeing
is it going to be mainly in the u.s or
is it going to be kind of like the
original modern warfare 2 where you were
jumping from you know all over the world
into like these different areas
it's definitely all over the world so i
think we saw a mission in amsterdam
um pretty much guarantee there'll be a
mission in mexico
they mentioned the middle east you know
we didn't see more than a couple levels
um but yeah it's more classicology it's
very globetrotting story
were you able to um kind of swap
perspectives or play as different
characters or were you always playing as
captain price or a soap oh that's a good
question um you weren't playing as price
i don't remember if you swapped
i did see um
[Music]
a lot of variety in missions so i can't
tell who's who it was like one of the
ones we saw was a night mission and they
mentioned you getting to do like night
operations and you know see the apache
gun ships come in and do those awesome
like gun runs at night
but because of that i actually couldn't
tell who it was we were playing as the
main protagonist of the last game
is is back
so it might be continuing their
development or it might jump around i
honestly couldn't tell you which one it
was just yet uh was there anything like
did they mention cross play cross
progression is that still going to be
uh expected for modern warfare 2 because
they have it on all their other call of
duties i feel like it would make sense
to you know have that capabilities with
modern warfare 2 as well this was
interesting at the very beginning the
presentation they talked um almost like
about a shared world experience
they were super vague about it
i think the developers said even
something along the lines of you seeing
other players doing things
in the game while you were playing which
sounded almost destiny like
but but then they didn't go into any
detail or answer any more questions on
that
so i do imagine it will have all of the
same quality of life stuff that
you know modern warfare currently has um
i you know i imagine that's cross cross
play crosstalk which they currently have
in the game right now awesome thank you
aaron so i think that's going to do it
for us all you guys watching please
write in the comments what you're hoping
to see what you're excited for and tell
us any rumors that you have and maybe we
can go around and myth bust some of them
if you want more detail also summer went
down to the event for us and she wrote
up a much more extensive post that you
can find over on gamespot
i'm serious like they told us a lot and
i'm just sort of like trying to keep
this pretty high level for modern
warfare fans so head on over there and
read what she has to say about it all
right so that'll do it for us we'll see
you guys later
[Music]
you